while Circle over's aim of retrieving
btsu leader Barden Schaefer was thwarted
by the heroic sacrifice of former true
son Captain Fred Lewis the devastating
Black Tusk attack on the White House led
to a number of essential Personnel being
forcibly abducted
agent your mission is to recover our
missing people some of these assets may
be familiar faces but there are also a
few new people who have helped you in
the fight to save what remains from the
ship
thank you
following the traumatic events of his
helicopter being targeted in a
subsequent rescue at the Mexican embassy
John is confronted with a deep-seated
fear and reluctance of returning to the
skies
okay
he's sleeping better
not really
nightmares yeah
back in the Hilo
surrounded waiting for your agents to
get me the hell out of that Embassy
that's normal it should get easier
that's what the doc said he'd give you
anything to help you sleep
I don't think he had anything to give
not like we've got a fresh supply of
sleeping pills lately
I could get you some wine from the
theater settlement if you want
yeah just what you need a drunk native
vets thinking up the White House I'd
rather have you drunk than dead
I'll be all right
not if you don't get some sleep
I just need something to do help take my
mind off what happened
we can always use a pilot
honestly Manny
I'm not ready to get back in the air
but if you need help with maintenance
and Logistics I'm happy to make Fernanda
and Casey's lives easier
that sounds like a great first step
I'll let Torres know she's got a
mechanic incoming
many reaches out to Jon who is dealing
with PTSD many assures John that he
understands and empathizes with his
current struggles while John
acknowledges that he's not yet ready to
resume flying he expresses a desire to
stay occupied by offering to handle
maintenance and Logistics tasks for the
other Pilots
that's good it's good to be working
again
nice to be able to contribute
you ready to get back up there
honestly
no
that's okay
I haven't had a nightmare in a couple
weeks but it's just
it's too soon
I get it
I'm sorry
it's okay
no I feel like I'm letting you down
you're not
but I do have a favor to ask you
anything
I need help setting up the castle
if we want to have transpo in and out of
the site I need someone who can tell me
if I'm setting up everything wrong
last thing we want to do is move
everyone in and then discover we can
move supplies you're looking to build a
landing site
yeah
well it's safer if you don't put it in
the middle of the settlement if we can
land there soaking our enemies that's a
good point
so what do you say
you want to help me rebuild the castle
despite time passing John remains
hesitant about getting back into the air
understanding Jones apprehension many
presents them with a new opportunity
recognizing Jon's expertise many assigns
them a crucial role in the cleanup and
rebuilding of the castle sediment
specifically focusing on tasks such as
establishing a landing site and
continued helicopter maintenance
everything is cleared and we have an
underground entrance that leads into the
settlement
if you don't know it's there you might
think we were ghosts disappearing Into
the Night
that's not creepy at all
it was Eva's idea you've been spending a
lot of time on the lately
she's a good kid reminds me of my little
sister but funnier
she's funny I think she has a crush on
you
she reminds me of my little sister
don't worry Manny you're the only one
trying to start something at the castle
I don't know what you're talking about
I'll be sure to tell Mario you said hi
John has embraced his new
responsibilities at the settlement and
has excelled in his role with the team's
Collective effort they've successfully
cleared a fresh Landing site and made
significant progress in setting up the
necessary infrastructure
throughout this journey John has formed
a close bond with Eva whom he cherishes
like a younger sister finding comfort
and support in their friendship
I'm sorry Manny but I really don't know
if I'll ever be ready to fly again
I figured as much
you've got a landing site but no pilot
I've got Pilots
and I've got a coordinator and a
mechanic that will make sure they get
home safe
you're not disappointed in me why would
I be disappointed
you've done everything you said you
would and you've gotten Eva to open up
and trust us
your new sister is even talking about
taking over the radio station
that's great but I'm a pilot who can't
fly you have to be at least a little
annoyed with me
if you lied to me and got back up there
with a team and got everyone killed then
I would be annoyed with you
but you telling me what you need
I can't be annoyed about that
takes too much energy to be pissed at
someone for not meeting unrealistic
expectations
okay seriously what has Mari done to you
you're all like calm and reasonable and
Zen or some [__]
she helped me realize that some of my
priorities may have not been that great
and like it or not we're family now and
I'd rather have my new brother safe than
trying to be something he's not and
putting us all in danger
so you're okay with me organizing the
pilots and maintaining the fleet more
than okay
that's exactly what we need
John confides in many expressing his
doubts about either being able to fly
again
understanding John's feelings many
reassures him revealing that he had
anticipated this outcome yet emphasizing
that his contribution in supporting the
pilots is equally valuable
moreover John's presence has been
instrumental in assisting Eva and
helping her to open up and developing
trusts in the community
John also observes that many appears to
be more relaxed than usual speculating
that Murray's presence may be
responsible for this positive change in
his demeanor
intelligence had recently surfaced
revealing a significant lead on the
whereabouts of John Yazi the Southwest
District of Washington DC became the
focus of attention as reports pinpointed
his presence at the choke control point
division agents wasted no time in
preparing for the mission in a
calculated and coordinated assault the
agents stormed the control Point
engaging in a firefight against the
entrenched black task forces
however as the agents fought their way
through the facility they received an
update John Yazi has been moved by the
Black Tusk to the nearby train tracks
adding an additional layer of urgency to
the mission
they needed to act swiftly in order to
intercept them before they managed to
get away with Jon
[Music]
first agents would need to neutralize
the target echo1 otherwise known as John
train steward
as they made their way through the train
tracks They encountered waves of black
dusk forces that stood in their way
despite this the agents pushed forward
eventually they would find train and
attack him head on
however once he was eliminated agents
would intercept black task comms that
confirmed that John Yazi was dropped off
at the NoHo control point 10 minutes ago
by the recruiter
with urgency the agents proceed towards
the no Hope Hotel
upon arrival they wasted no time and
immediately got to work in eliminating
the Hostile forces that occupied the
compound
as the agents cleared out the threats
and brought the hotel under their
control it was then that Manny's voice
was heard over the comms saying that
John Yazi had been cited at the Rayburn
house
frustrated that they had missed him
again they knew that time was a factor
and quickly made their way over to the
building on the Eastern side of the
district
[Music]
at the Rayburn house agents would
encounter waves of Black Tusk forces
however through the fighting they would
get disorientated and eventually lost
in frustration they would punch a deer
to their surprise this didn't help and
it will be another 10 minutes of running
around in circles before they realized
where they needed to be
eventually they would find and confront
Black Tusk leader Dave Rhino bishop and
while they were able to eliminate him
all the time wasted earlier on meant
that they had missed Jon once again
many announces that Jon has now been
found he is at the Space Administration
HQ
the agents again blaming the deer vowed
to come back later on venderson is on
the menu tonight however first they must
catch up with Jon for three years yet
again moved on
CE at the facility the agents pushed
forward through the hordes of Black Tusk
however their progress was abruptly
interrupted when they were ambushed by a
rogue agent
despite the challenging encounter the
agents persevered and triumphed over the
Rogue although they did question their
decision to undertake the mission with
the added difficulty of four directives
it was discovered that the ptsu
operative Gabriel Dynamite Gonzalez was
holding John Yazi hostage
while the division agents were busy
taking care of dynamite and her troops
jtf forces successfully Infiltrate The
Compound and Rescue Jon
no PTSD
you sleeping okay
I'll let you know tomorrow
I just got home Manny can I at least
watch the black test stank off me before
you start the interrogation
sorry you're right
look I know you're worried about Mari
but you really don't have to be
they were good to me I'm sure Mario will
be fine she's worth more to them alive
anyway
what do you mean
your woman is brilliant
she's like a super genius when it comes
to this whole sustainable fish stuff and
she's pregnant
I don't know if you've noticed but
haven't seen a lot of pregnant people or
kids running around
what are you saying I'm just saying
if I were trying to rebuild civilization
it would be way easier to indoctrinate a
baby than an angry teenager who
remembers what the before times were
like
to keep people in line and follow orders
you get them when they're young when
they're desperate
people with hope who know better
those people are dangerous
kids don't know any better
they learn what you teach them
they believe what you believe and if I
were going to build a cult
let's start with the kids
that
that does not make me feel better
after the successful Rescue Mission many
reaches out to John to check on his
well-being sensing the need for a moment
to gather himself before diving into an
official debrief John requests some time
to catch his breath
however many consumed by worry for
Murray's safety overlooks the importance
of giving John the space he needs
fortunately John understands Manny's
concerns and reassures him that Murray
is safe and is being looked after
Eva Garcia a history major at Kinley
College returned to campus after a
Thanksgiving spent with the family
alongside her studies Eva ran a podcast
where she spoke about whatever was on
her mind with the side objective of
gaining extra credit
after the outbreak Kinley College faced
a drastic change as the school closed
its doors due to the escalating crisis
the effects of the outbreak quickly
became apparent as students and faculty
started falling ill
Eva caught in the midst of the chaos
found her dormitory transformed into a
makeshift quarantine facility the
overwhelmed Healthcare could no longer
handle the growing number of six
students
with no other choice Eva made the
difficult decision to leave keenly
college and head back to her home in
Florida
leaving behind the safety of the college
Eva found herself on a dubious ride
towards Washington DC she made the
decision to exit the vehicle and seek
alternative means of getting back to her
family
but I wanted to let you know we left
Kenley I'm on my way
it just might take me a little longer
than expected
Chad was really with Chad and I knew I
shouldn't have gotten in his car but it
was that or wait for a Sarah evacuation
bus
Chad seemed like the safer option
I'm okay
he tried some stupid [__] but I'm okay
we were outside of Baltimore so I'm just
gonna head down 95 until I can get
another ride or get home to you
whichever comes first
mom if you got this
make me posole
eventually Eva would have to abandon her
Long Walk Home the weather was getting
too much to handle so she decided to
wait it out until spring where the local
community she stumbled across
hey Mom it's not really safe to travel
right now the roads are questionable and
the weather is [__] I thought it was
supposed to get warmer the further south
you went but this winter is like extra
cold and snowy
maybe in the spring I can start walking
again but for now I found this group and
I think it's smarter if I stay with them
for a while
they set up a community in an apartment
complex outside of DC they've got plenty
of food and there's even some people
talking about building rooftop gardens
and raising chickens in the spring
if they can find some chickens I hope
you're getting these
I'm a little worried that you haven't
called me back
and now your phone is going straight to
voicemail
mom
call me back okay
I love you
from the division recruited novel we
learned that the settlement or Community
called Athena was a village in the
hollowed out remnants of the city the
building had once been luxury condos
inhabited by the wealthy
when the dust had settled a group of
survivors had gathered there determined
to make the best of it
the concentration of almost 40 families
was no accident they huddled together
for safety in the wake of the viral
apocalypse the most dangerous thing left
in the world was other people
Myra recruited's protagonist was pushed
into the role of Athena's head of
community security and whether she
wanted it or not she was the best person
for the job
however over time the position had
forced her to make some calls that
rubbed people the wrong way
and in some cases led to a loss of life
hey Mom
but in case you're still worried about
me I just wanted to let you know I'm
good
Athena is a pretty tall place we get
attacked every once in a while but we've
got food and Myers making sure we're
safe and I even made a friend her little
brother Kazi
don't worry it's not romantic or
anything we're just friends he's barely
18 so yeah a little young for me
don't worry Mom although it could help
pass the time there is no danger of me
getting knocked up by some kid while I
wait out the Apocalypse in Maryland love
you call me back
as we would find out later on in the
story it wouldn't remain happy and
peaceful at Athena for very long
Athena would come under attack by the
outcasts although Myra had put many
hours into preparing the community for
this very event there was just too many
of them
however just before the last lines of
Defense would fall the sudden appearance
of division agents came to the rescue
Athena would survive another day but the
community was looking a little worse for
wear with a number of casualties
Myra having done the absolute best that
she could with what she had at hand was
praised by the leader of the division
cell
but upon learning of their mission to
find out why Supply shipments weren't
making it through and if fixed how this
could help the community Myra asked to
join them provided that Athena would be
cared for
but you know we're moving guess you
shouldn't believe everything people say
about the division
some agents saved Athena last week lost
one of their own in the fight and Myra
joined them on some secret mission
[__]
between losing her and the damage to the
complex and with winter coming it's
really not smart for us to stay here
anymore
honestly it hasn't been the same since
qazi died
true Sons got him
anyway the division offered to take us
in
sent a group to move us to the castle I
don't know if that's code or if we're
like really moving into a castle but
yeah if you ever get your phone working
again and check your voicemail you can
find me at the castle
and let's see Mom love you hope you're
not dead
sorry Mom sorry
call me back okay
I love you
bye
eventually the jtf would take either and
the number of the remaining Athena
Sizzlers to the recently reopened Castle
settlement over time many would assist
either for job placement to fund the
perfect fit for how she could do her
part in the running of this new
community
you'll eventually learn of a media
background and asks if she would like to
get the settlement radio back up and
running to play music make announcements
and overall boost morale
ever agrees but it wasn't so long after
this time that Eva along with a number
of other Personnel were forcibly
abducted by the Black Tusk
agents receive Intelligence on either's
possible location at the Eclipse fuel
Depot and quickly mobilized to clear the
area of hostile true sons and secure The
Outpost
however this search proves fruitless as
either as nowhere to be found
frustration mounts as the agents regroup
but many interrupts their disappointment
with urgent news he announces a huge
surge of Black Tusk activity at the
Department of Justice raising the
possibility of finding leads on Eva's
whereabouts
agents redirect their focus and set off
towards the Department of Justice
agents proceed maneuvering through the
courtyard and engaging in combat with
the true Sons
they would make their way through to the
underground car park
finally they come face to face with a
high value Target
after dispatching the Hostile leader the
agents would discover a crucial clue a
piece of abandoned communication
equipment that points to either's
possible whereabouts
the urgency of the situation intensifies
as they realize she may be at the Navy
Plaza
hostile radio
agent gets a Navy Plaza
agents swiftly Converge on the compound
the true sons have fortified the area
that the agents undeterred navigate the
barricades and overcome wave after wave
of hostile forces
their perseverance pays off as they
successfully neutralize two prominent
leaders within the true Sun's ranks
amid the chaos of battle another
communication from Eva has discovered
becomes evident that she is deliberately
leaving behind hints and break crumbs
leading the agents closer to her
location
with this new information the agents
follow either's Trail and fight on to
ensure her safe return
oh okay
where the hell are you taking me
we're closing in on them he was at the
National Archives
agents confront Fierce resistance from
the true Sons upon arriving at the
entrance of the National Archive
Building
they navigate the structure eliminating
hostiles and definitely not getting lost
again
eventually they would face off against a
true Sun leader once eliminated Manny's
voice would once again be heard of the
earpieces
wasting no time he announces the
discovery of Eva's whereabouts she's at
the Viewpoint Museum
the true sons have fortified the
facility posing a formidable challenge
for the agents
with unwavering determination they fight
their way through the heavily guarded
entrance
as they delve deeper into the facility
waves of enemies grow in size and
intensity until eventually they come
face to face with another rogue agent
however the Agents come prepared armed
with their shooting lightning gun that
swiftly dispatches the Rogue
pressing forward they reach the
broadcasting area where the true Sons
make their final stand
among them Lieutenant Thompson stands as
their final challenge
but while all of this is playing out the
jtf arrives mounting a successful rescue
operation to secure Eva Garcia and bring
it back to the safety of the castle
settlement
once Eva was safely back at the castle
sediment many were Chicken on her
Circle over
how not oh she didn't really make me do
anything like she wanted me to record
some radio show to entertain the troops
but it wasn't a big deal or anything
you don't think that's weird
not really you asked me to do the same
thing yeah
but how did she know that you're a DJ
well she said she liked my podcast
I'm sorry I never got the extra credit
since the school sort of died
Natalia listened to your podcast
what else did she tell you
nothing really
played me some Isaac recordings tried to
get me to use them on the show
uh Manny you might want to stop taking
your comms to bed the black tasks know
like way too much about your sex life
dude
but either said that everything was all
good she even referred to Natalia as net
like they were close friends now Natalia
even said that she used to listen to a
podcast at keenly College
she wanted Eva to record a radio show to
entertain the troops sort of a morel
boosting thing and Eva pointed out that
this isn't so much different to what
many wants her to do
but she did say that Natalia asked her
to play some Isaac recordings on her
show
maybe this was to be used as a
propaganda piece
the blacktest soldiers have been
fighting for a few months now perhaps
this was to pick them up and remind them
what they're fighting for
the future of the country and to get
there they need to remove that Rogue
operation calling themselves the
division
so once again we're hearing that the
Target that was supposedly being held
captive was actually well cared for by
the Black Tusk
so with the Black Tusk actually the good
guys
no I'm not going to humor this for even
one second
the amount of crap they have pulled over
the previous months 100 says otherwise
this is just a ploy to gain more support
for this side
if you were going to take over the
country and label yourself as the
legitimate savior you'd have an easier
time with the support of more than just
the military under your employment
you want the community leaders the
voices the ones going above and beyond
to rebuild Society
would that support behind you there
would be few that wouldn't have a hard
time fighting against you
Natalia is using a new tactic attacking
the division head-on has proven
ineffective time and time again
now she's going after the one thing that
the division needs to survive more than
anything else
the support of society the vulnerable
the innocent
without them there really isn't too much
more they have to fight for
the government is gone the
infrastructure is more or less obsolete
in most major cities that we are aware
of
Society was the last thing that the
division was fighting for and if they
have already chosen which side is the
right side what more use are the
division to the people of the US
fortunately even the most recently
rescued civilian Eva Garcia doesn't
believe a word Natalia is saying
kindness how [__] cool is that in the
face of unspeakable evil and certain
death this group of chaos demons chose
to dig into their trauma and be nice to
people
don't fall for that [__] this is like
day one of fascism 101. do you want
apartheid or indentured servitude
because that's how you get apartheid and
indentured servants
during a catch-up Lauren would tell many
of the hardship they are going through
at their current settlement so many
offers a solution
hey Manny how's it going Lauren
everything okay
sure we lost some people this week but
we're keeping it together as best we can
sorry to hear that sorry you say it
you need anything
honestly
a new place to live it's a little
crowded around here but I'm working on a
solution
it's not ready yet but it's safe and
warm and if you don't mind living in a
construction site I could send a team to
movie tomorrow
sounds perfect thank you Manny
offered to locate Lauren in a girlfriend
Amanda to the castle settlement to give
them a safe place to live and help
rebuild
as with anyone during these times Lauren
and Amanda would be given jobs to help
keep the community functioning everyone
needed to do their part if these
settlements were going to survive
Mari I'd like you to meet Amanda
oh nice to meet you Amanda
she reads lips right
yeah but I can translate
you sure you're up for this
Amanda says I'm deaf not dead I can feed
the fish
of course sorry just some of this stuff
is weirdly Technical and not sure how
good I am at explaining any of it
we all have to start somewhere if we
mess up we try again
okay cool sorry I've just
I've never worked with a deaf person
before
I'm totally messing this up aren't I
we're used to it
so how long have you girls been working
together
three years
were you our interpreter at school
she was my tutor before I got the Nerf
to ask her out
all right I didn't realize you were
lovers
Amanda wants to know how old you are
40 why
she said she must be older than she
looks if she called us lovers
I'm totally messing this up
seriously it's fine just maybe we stick
to the work instead of a small talk I
don't think you're good at the small
talk
oh my God I am not a people person
what did she say
obviously
it was truly Amanda's idea
this is a genius
explain how it works again
to provide some shade in the summer and
reduce heat loss in the winter we've
made these rafts out of foam the roots
go directly into the tanks and feed the
plants making it easier to harvest
what's the substrate for the plants
rock wool inflation found some at an
abandoned construction site
I figured there wasn't enough to inflate
a new project but it was perfect for
this
it's like a proper hydroponic Farm
Amanda says
technically Hydro requires additional
chemical inputs
this is a closed system
so we have a proper aquaponic grow
operation
where'd you learn how to do all this
before the green poison we were talking
about starting an urban farm after
graduation
the original plan was to grow tilapia
and salad and do a food truck
that's amazing we're really lucky you're
randomly assigned to this project
it wasn't random we asked Manny for this
assignment
oh
and tell me that
I think this might be his idea of a joke
we really need to work on a sense of
humor
it turns out that Lauren and Amanda had
requested this work detail and that they
have some good experience in aquaponics
which is basically a system where waste
produced by farmed fish were other
aquatic creatures supplies the nutrients
for plants grown hydroponically which in
turn purifies the water
so for a fish farm this is fantastic for
filtering the water but will also
provide another source of nutrition
through the plants being grown
it's not it's just going to take a while
that's fine
we started the cardamom seeds last week
we should be able to harvest Greens in
another week or two but it'll be a
couple months before we have seed pods
thank you
I've never heard of green cardamom seeds
being a pregnancy craving is that an
Indian thing
oh I don't want to just eat the pods I
want to make Karma oh that makes more
sense
thanks again
and please keep this to yourself or not
out of Olivia and I've miscarried before
so I'd rather not have to have those
conversations if it happens again
I don't want to put Manny through that
understood
okay that's funny
that's funny Amanda said her lips are
sealed
thank you Amanda
and thank you for figuring out how to
grow the cardamom
you girls really are the future
this is obviously earlier on before Mari
had told many that she was pregnant
sometime in the first three to four
months of pregnancy but we can see that
the girls have been working with Murray
for a little while at this point as
Murray seems to be picking up a bit of
Amanda's sign language
agents receive Intel that Lauren might
be in the Midtown East District of
Washington DC their first destination is
the Fallen Crane's control Point
currently under the control of the Black
Tusk
their numbers were huge but the agents
came prepared
using their Aces and eights build they
were also rocking the ridiculously
overpowered determined Talent on their
maxman rifle they must have been feeling
particularly lazy that day
after clearing the compound they
intercepted a hostile cons
Ole radio we intercepted
that's after something and she's not
sharing what that is
these columns revealed that Vikram Malik
and Lauren were being taken to the odia
tech office
with no time to waste the agents swiftly
set their course and move out on their
mission to rescue Lauren and Vikram
arriving at the office they find a small
contingent of blacktest soldiers
guarding the entrance
after making quick work of them they
climb a ladder making their way into the
building next door and navigate through
to the tech office via the balcony
window
here there was a much larger
concentration of Black Tusk but this was
no problem for the super broken One-Shot
body shot Talent
once the leader on site was eliminated
another hostile comms was recovered
section
Lauren has been relocated to the MLK
Memorial Library
next stop the agents will be going to
the Eastern side of the district with
the black task of set up an outpost at
the library
[Music]
the agents wasted no time plowing into
the guards defending the facility
eventually jtf backup would arrive and
provide a much needed distraction while
the agents managed to find The High
Ground
it wasn't long before the Black Tusk
commanding officers had been taken down
and the site was under their control
retail store we're closing in honor
Unfortunately they were too slow Lauren
has now been moved on and has been
spotted heading towards the odia retail
store
in the northeasternmost part of the
district agents pushed towards the front
doors of the store
after clearing the Black Tusk they
noticed the entrance had been barricaded
however they found a way through the
service door below
the black task on site was taken by
surprise and it wasn't long before the
high value Target made itself known
after absolutely murdering the target
Manny's voice could be heard over their
earpieces
you got the target nice
making their way to the stronghold the
agents took a few moments to assist the
heavily fortified entrance
once satisfied with how they were going
to approach the situation they wasted no
time in taking out the Black Tusk units
on site and proceeding through the front
doors
Lauren's been working with Murray
running the aquaponics
bring her here it's almost like Sokolova
took our people to run parts of her
operation
pushing through the compound eliminating
countless hostiles another enemy
communication would be intercepted
the only reason to convert the card
greenhouses would be to do an aquaponic
separation like we have at the castle
the garden has filtered water and
recycle it back to the fish
Lauren's their prisoner but it sounds
more like she's advising the black
Tuscon running an aquaponics Workshop
what the hell's going on here
the agents continue their Relentless
Advance battling through room after room
facing a hold of Black Tusk soldiers
accompanied by their warhounds
but the agents were undeterred making
precise shots and effortly dispatching
enemies left and right
as they push deeper into the library
they come face to face with the Black
Tusk commander who joins the fight
but the agents had stupidly lost all of
their Stacks shooting a piece of
equipment on the ground so it meant that
they actually had to aim during this
encounter
is falling apart
area secure
once eliminated many announced that he
is sending someone in to bring Lauren
back to the castle
although I wonder why the agents could
have done it I mean they hit it there
anyway
once Lauren was back in the castle many
would see how she was doing
wait I just wanted to know why you were
helping them helping who the black task
I wasn't helping them
we heard you talking to them about the
gardens oh that they asked me a question
I wasn't helping them I was just
answering their questions Mac attract
hostages were not supposed to openly
antagonize their captors if they want to
stay alive that makes sense
so close changing tactics aligning with
the true Sons they're taking
infrastructure
this isn't a short-term solution if
they're setting up basis in local food
security they must be getting ready to
build a stronghold for winter can I go
now I really like to see my girlfriend
yeah sorry I apologize to Amanda for me
no need and don't worry we'll get Murray
back
I don't know where the medical team took
her but I'm sure she's fine medical team
yeah when they first captured us a
medical team took Cindy and Mari Vic was
freaking out but I'm fine so I'm sure
they're fine
Lauren disparately attempts to get away
from many hoping to reunite with Amanda
however many driven by the need to
uncover the truth behind Lauren's
cooperation with Natalya in the Black
Tusk
annoyed and cornered Lauren finally
gives her reasons
many listens intently and recognizes
Natalia's long-term plans including the
need to secure sustainable Food
suppliers if they were to succeed in
taking over
though many finds it hard to believe he
tries to understand the situation
considering Murray's safety and
well-being in the process
much like the last two Lauren was
treated pretty well by Natalya in the
black task
well I'm pretty sure no one is buying
this many seems to be a little bit
confused however we'll give them the
benefit of the doubt he's worried about
Mario after all so he's probably looking
a little deeper than needed
but there may be something to be
concerned about here if we peer this
calm up with the last one where Mario
was talking about her concerns around
having another miscarriage it shows that
Murray's been having these fears for
months now
she would have these fears anyway but
given the state of the country these
concerns would obviously only be more
intense
things are a lot more dangerous for
expectant mothers and their babies at
this time
so when you're hearing this piece that
Murray and Cindy were taken away by
medical personnel and that Vic is
freaking out about it
was right after they were captured so
hopefully it doesn't actually mean
anything is wrong instead this could be
just to show Murray everything they have
how set up they are to be able to
provide any medical care she should need
we need to remember the image that was
given to the season where Natalia is
standing over the top of the Personnel
who captured in a puppeteer sort of way
is this the way Natalia is going to gain
Murray's loyalty by using mari's fears
about her baby and its future
even when we rescue her she's still
going to have the same concerns
Is it alive is it healthy is the birth
gonna be okay
Natalia has a lot of the things that
Murray needs to feel safe so how will
this impact the community going forward
will this drive some sort of divide
and what does Cindy have to do with any
of this
born and raised in Virginia Dr Mitchell
Billings grew up as the son of a career
military man he watched over the years
her deployments would transform his
father
the events his father had witnessed
during his deployment had taken a toll
on his psyche and when he returned home
to his family he was a Broken Man
hostile and reactive
he experienced hyper vigilance and
paranoia causing him to constantly lock
every door and continually look over his
shoulder for perceived threats he often
suffered from nightmares and flashbacks
that would cause him to relive past
traumatic events again and again as if
they were happening for the first time
being back home with his family he left
an outlet for his anger which meant he
regularly engaged and displaced
aggression towards them
recognizing his immense struggles and
the pain he was going through his wife
took it upon herself to try and help her
husband
he'd always loved to use his hands and
took great pride intending to things
outside of their home so with this in
mind she encouraged him to try building
birdhouses on their porch outside
being in nature made him feel better
along with a sense of purpose and
satisfaction with completing a birdhouse
for the garden's woodpeckers or sparrows
gardening combined repetition with a
creative outcome which was soothing for
him helping to relieve stress and
anxiety
he could lose himself in gentle
movements when gardening and Achieve
mindfulness
he found that growing things from seeds
or saplings or simply keeping his Lawns
looking healthy brought him a wonderful
sense of satisfaction
witnessing his mother's ability to
handle his father's rage and PTSD
through acts of service patience and
concentration Mitchell recognized her
effective coping strategies for stress
relief
inspired by her emotional intelligence
and determined to mend wounded souls he
pursued Psychiatry as his field of study
specializing in treating soldiers
returning from conflict zones
developing expertise in PTSD and complex
PTSD Mitchell completed his residency at
Walter Reed General Hospital before the
outbreak of the green poison
when the true Sons seized control of
Walter Reed he saw an opportunity to
continue his work by healing soldiers in
need
with his guidance many of the true Sons
recognized that their decisions had
stemmed from Pain and Trauma they came
to understand that breaking the cycle
was possible enabling them to make
healthier choices for themselves and
their community
later on Billings would be rescued by
the division where he was being held by
the true Sons at a Detention Center
once freed he'll continue with his
mission of healing and Rehabilitation of
those in need
after his rescue at many's request Dr
Mitchell Billings would begin sessions
with members of the team in DC
how are you feeling today Wally
good
weird we're good
it's going to take time to adjust and
find your role in this community
oh I've already got a job and I'm not
alone I've got Fred
that's good is your boyfriend
oh God no Fred
we're just friends
you couldn't handle this
so I'm pretty sure he's still broken
after the [__] his ex put him
through
well I'm glad to see you haven't lost
your sense of humor if you're not
laughing you're crying and if you're
crying you're dying
I'm through a lot haven't you
you wouldn't believe it
no one ever believes the truth
you know
I find sometimes people surprise you if
you let them
that's hard doc
to let people in
if you never let them in they can never
disappoint you
well you know sometimes people use their
strength and humor as a shield
or a weapon
exactly
this is a safe place you don't have to
protect yourself anymore
you can put down the armor damn it
you're good doc
when did you join the true Sons
[__]
guess we're diving deep today
it seemed like a good idea at the time
even with what happened to Roosevelt
Island
I didn't know [__] all about that
my job was keeping the lights on you
focus on the job you can lose sight of a
lot of [__] up [__]
do you think Ridgeway kept you in the
dark on purpose
I think everyone does that
there's no way for anyone to know
everything so people only tell you what
you need to know to get the job done
that's leadership and chain of command
you follow orders and Trust they are for
a reason
in the end you decided to stop following
orders what changed we did
Ridgeway wanted to cut our losses
we all know about acceptable loss
we know about collateral damage but
Anderson he was chasing Danger
he was courting loss
he wasn't trying to stop the
hemorrhaging
with Ridgeway we were doing what we had
to to save the most people
with Anderson
he just wanted power
how else do you explain him partnering
with Sokolova
did anyone else hear a little something
there around her feelings towards Lewis
this wasn't pointed out but it certainly
fills my need for some scandalous
Revelations
however regardless Mitch would
eventually break through Wally's walls
and find out how she is really feeling
it's not that she didn't know about a
lot of the horrible stuff that the true
Sons were doing it's more that she chose
to focus on the work she'd been given
and ignore what was potentially
happening around her
because with Ridgeway they actually felt
like they were helping and saving people
but after Anderson took over everything
changed
it didn't seem like he cared about what
was happening to the true Sons just that
he was trying to gain power
weird
like I don't know how the hell I got
here what do you mean
it doesn't seem fair that I'm alive
that Maddie sent the agents to bring me
back and most of my men are dead
on this circumstance survivor's guilt is
understandable
I know but it's more than that I I just
I don't know how I got this lucky I
don't know why Manny would do that for
me
your brothers in arms you've been
through a lot together
yeah but I followed Ridgeway I could
have been a spy for socalova are you a
spy
[__] no
why do you think Manny would put his
people at risk to bring you in
because he wanted to squeeze me for
Intel
that's why he sent me the you dog
do you feel like this is an
interrogation
not really no
why do you think Manny sent you to me to
talk
make sure I'm okay
why would he do that
because he's worried I'm not okay
why would he rescue you
because he cares about me
why would he bring you in
because he trusts me
how do you feel now
like I owe my life
and how are you going to pay back that
debt
I have no idea
you know it's not something you can ever
pay back right
yeah
the list shouldn't really gets [__] up
thanks Doc
don't do anything rash
Louis still feels extremely guilty for
what he's done and even more so because
many would risk the life of others to
rescue him yet most of the minators
command were killed
many genuinely cares for Lewis but this
only makes him feel more guilty
Lewis knows that he owes many everything
and will do everything in his power to
pay back that debt
however as we know by now Lewis wouldn't
have much time left after this
conversation as he would meet us in
protecting the White House following
Natalya's attack on the compound
do we really have to do this
we don't have to do anything
if you don't find these sessions helpful
we don't need to continue
I just don't know what I'm doing here in
these sessions or in DC
DC
you missed your team in New York
I miss my family in New York
interesting
ah don't do that [__]
do you feel like this isn't your family
anymore
I don't know these people
do you feel like Manny is replacing you
I feel like he doesn't need me this
isn't my home anymore
how do you feel in New York
like they want me there
they don't just need me
they actually want me to be there
you don't think people want you to be
here
I think the longer I stay and the more
things change the less anyone would care
if I left
not like there's much love for the
division around here
frankly it feels like you think I'm a
traitor
and I swear to God if I I hear one more
person talk [__] about fate
you know I used to be CIA making a
murderer look like an accident is like
spycraft 101.
well we now know where Kelso has been
hiding out during the season she's been
taking some time out with her family in
New York but also that she no longer
feels like she has a place in DC that
she isn't needed anymore
she also said that she suspects that
people see her as a traitor now not to
break the immersion here but I fully
feel like this could be a jab back at me
for all the perhaps misplaced videos
about Kelso being a traitor or Rogue if
we go back a year or so when this was
likely being written I was in full swing
with my what the hell is Kelso doing
videos where I was accusing her of doing
all sorts of things against the division
I'm probably just over analyzing but I'm
totally taking some responsibility for
this
in all fairness I really like Kelso's
character she just terrifies me and
she's a little bit crazy however I'll
admit I like a little bit of crazy
fine
anything I should be worried about I'm
not going to tell you what I talk about
with my other patients no of course not
I didn't mean you know you don't have to
take care of everyone
you don't have to control everything
of course not
it's okay to let go and enjoy yourself
Manny
I know how to enjoy myself
I know
how are things with Maori
good
I like her she's smart she challenges me
to get out of my head
funny strikes me as a very cerebral
person
he is but she uh
fully commits to anything she does
so when we're together we're very
together if
do I really have to talk about this
nope you don't
but you should talk to Mari
about the baby
yeah
I want it she wants it we want it but
and we don't know if it's smart or good
timing
well there is never a good timing
well there's bad timing and there's
giving birth in a war zone
babies are born in war zones all the
time
I don't know how to do this job and be a
dad what do you mean
I have to stay calm and measured and
make tough choices
I don't want my kid to think I'm some
cold heartless [__] workaholic
fathers come in all shapes and sizes
I guess but if I'm gonna have a kid I
want to be with that kid
you know you could learn a few things
from Wally and Fred about parenting
they don't have any kids
no
but they know that sometimes the best
way to decompress and manage stress
is to accept that there is no way to
solve the problem
if you can laugh at your situation you
won't be consumed by it
this particular session just confirms
exactly what we know about many as well
as the way he's been feeling of this
last season
is an intense need to be of control in
every situation and is a deep-seated
fear about not being good enough to
Father his unborn child
it takes on an immense amount of
responsibility and deems himself as the
sole person responsible for the outcome
and everything that has happened in DC
he needs to find a way to decompress to
learn to share the load with other
trusted individuals around him recognize
the good he has done and learn to let go
of the guilty feels or it will
eventually consume him
is this the start of a downward spiral
for many do we need to talk to Kelso and
get her back to DC
intelligence had recently surfaced
revealing that Mitchell Billings was
being held somewhere in the Constitution
Hall District of Washington DC further
inspection revealed that he's been held
at the haunted house control point
arriving at The Outpost agents were
greeted by an enormous unit of true Sons
but the agents were prepared for this
with their overwhelming training and
Firepower including the super magical
Slayer snowball Cannon they were able to
make short work of them and upon their
elimination many would be heard over the
comms
a war camp
and therapist
taking him to treat people maybe I've
been wrong about her
ignoring many's doubts the agents waste
no time and head off towards the outcast
Work Camp
arriving at the location that was marked
on the map the agents clear a small
group of true sons that were mulling
about on the street then without warning
they were ambushed by a much larger
group coming from a balcony above
fortunately for them the agents were
wearing their Logitech G Pro X wireless
headsets with 50 mil drivers and
pro-grade Precision Audio so they heard
them coming from a mile away hashtag
sponsored once the hostels were cleared
out they made their way deeper into the
camp and came across the high value
Target and after eliminating him they
were able to intercept a hostile cons
burnout
get to the nest
Mitchell is advising Natalya on the
state of omen but also gives the agents
the last location he'd been spotted
[Music]
throwing all caution into the wind the
agents charge into the site with
absolutely no planning and would quickly
pay the price
agent killed
after recomposing themselves they would
rush back in this time with backup
despite the challenging weather it
wasn't long before this site 2 was
cleared and brought under friendly
control
but unfortunately they would discover
that Mitchell is long gone from the area
putting him on the radio what the hell
is he doing
the agents replenish their suppliers and
head off to the true Sons broadcast
Outpost
traveling to the southeasternmost part
of the district the agents would come
across a lightly defended building
making their way to the roof they
surprised another group of true sons who
seemed completely unaware of the murder
of their friends just moments ago on the
street below
entering the building it wasn't long
before the leader on site made his
presence known
but once again he alongside his troops
were merely a hindrance and were quickly
dispatched
headquarters we gotta move
[Music]
burying on the side of caution the
agents scope out the entrance of the DCd
headquarters before pushing ahead mainly
because their usual Run and Gun approach
proved unsuccessful a couple of times in
a row Dr Billings has helped all of us
heal and work together
be careful agent I don't like that so
gloves brought him here
agent requesting backup
moving through the compound it was
starting to get pretty clear to the
agents that these true Sons had a lot
harder than the previous ones building
up to this Mission and that maybe they
could have equipped a more flexible
build however regardless they pushed on
thank you
not only were they fighting more
ferociously but they were in much larger
numbers Mitchell was obviously very
close by
hostile radio we intercepted
I'm really sorry to hear you've been
having a hard time
driving decisions
please take a chance to breathe and
recalibrate yourself
not just your weapon thanks dog
I don't understand what she's trying to
do
they continue to push through the
facility attempting to waste as little
time as possible to catch up with
Mitchell before he's once again moved on
eventually they would be confronted by
the true Sun's leader Lieutenant young
and after taking out his guards they
turned their attention to him and while
using potentially the most painful and
impractical weapon in the game it would
slowly take him down
that goes on me
got you agent
God
foreign
s I'll see you back at the castle agent
please come see me if you ever want to
talk
when Mitchell had been safely returned
to the castle settlement Manny would
catch up with him for a debrief
yeah what is she wrong with you just to
do my job
whatever soldiers are approaching
burnout she wanted me to do psych evals
on them did you not all
but a few before your agent rescued me
she didn't hurt you or force you to do
my job no she didn't force me
she asked me to talk to some troubled
soldiers and I talk to them
I took a nose
it doesn't matter that I was a prisoner
I'm a doctor first
you don't choose your patience you don't
choose who gets help you help the people
who need it regardless of their
loyalties
is there anything you can tell me
I can't give you any specifics on my
patients
what about patterns
what do they say about Sokolova any
patterns of abuse manipulation control
no Manny
quite the opposite
the only reason her soldiers are still
here is because of her leadership
they feel respected listened to and
cared for
even in death she finds a way to honor
them they adore her
mature was asked to help her by
performing psych evaluations on Black
Tusk soldiers after all these months
some of them were starting to show signs
of burnout and depression
Mitchell says he was treated well and
that this is his job and he was happy to
assist her with a request his mission is
and has always been to help those in
need regardless of what side they're on
many digs deeper trying to find out
anything that Natalia is doing in the
background but Mitchell says it's
actually much different to how many
imagines her control of the black task
would be
his soldiers respect her and feel valued
she is the only reason they're still
doing what they do given the situation
the world is in right now
it's pretty obvious that many is really
starting to struggle with how all of
these prisoners have been treated I mean
he's glad I'm sure especially since he
still hasn't been able to recover Mari
but this is all really starting to
confuse him based on what he is hearing
from these debriefs Natalia is nothing
like he imagined should be
I've been calling this out since the
very first rescue Natalia is playing a
new game one that paints her in the
black task in a different light
but in reality I don't think anything
has changed she still needs to be
stopped she's just attacking the
remaining jtf and division agents in a
different way she's casting doubt and on
top of this she's attempting to turn
civilians over to their side
sadly I think many is a little bit
vulnerable right now at with Murray gone
in the pregnancy he isn't in the right
State of Mind to make proper judgments
Murray Singh is the director of the
Washington DC Aquarium when animal
rights groups protested the inhumane
captivity of the aquarium's Dolphins
they cited it as animal cruelty and from
here they began a number of long drawn
out lawsuits filed against the aquarium
with the impact of these lawsuits and
the outcry from the public the aquarium
started to lose Revenue at an alarming
pace
unable to afford hiring a spokesperson
the responsibility fell solely on
Murray's shoulders to be the voice and
face of the organization they soon
realized that keeping the Dolphins at
the aquarium was no longer a feasible
and ethical option for them and
immediately began focusing the efforts
and funds on rehoming the memos to a
local sanctuary as releasing them back
into the wild was not a possibility some
of these animals had spent the entirety
of their lives at the aquarium and
others had been captured when they were
so young their captivity was the only
life they really knew
although devastating to say goodbye to
these Dolphins as the aquarium staff had
built such close bonds with them over
the years ultimately they had to put the
animal's well-being Above All Else and
so even with such great financial cost
to the aquarium along with the financial
strain from the lawsuits Murray made the
hard decision to re-home them
of course this was the plan before the
dollar flew outbreak caused the whole
city to be put into lockdown
Murray embodies weariness
professionalism in a practical approach
potentially to a fault she understands
that certain things need to be done in
order to achieve objectives
following the division's successful
Rescue of the aquarium community and
agent Kelso's absence in New York Murray
enters a relationship with many
upon Kelso's return many discovers
Mary's pregnancy which revitalizes his
commitment to restoring the Castle's
settlement and transforming it into a
secure Sanctuary for their expanding
family
thank you for dinner I told you I owed
you won
it's been a really long time since I've
had a meal this good I'm glad you
enjoyed it
thank you for the Easy Company
when you invited me over for fish tacos
I wasn't sure if it was some kind of
code
you know for um
and uh never mind
I have kind of an awkward question okay
what's the deal with you and Kelso it's
a deal are you two together oh God no no
that's not she's beautiful but not my
type too chaotic and Young
good to know
would you like a drink I got some wine
from the theater settlement traded three
fish for it they say it's quote the good
stuff
I'm gonna need to jump in here and golf
track for a little bit I've been married
for around eight years I certainly
wouldn't have any idea of what it's like
in the dating scene these days it's been
almost a decade and to be fair if I look
back my social awkwardness meant that I
could barely even string a decent
sentence together I fully relied on the
fact that I was a big okay looking dude
who like to lift a lot of Weights back
then my courting ritual of a potential
mate could have been compared to a
Silverback Gorilla beating his chest or
perhaps a dark Ahead version of the
American animated series of the late 90s
Johnny Bravo hey baby I know what you're
thinking out of the statue get off its
pedestal well surprise I'm real sugar
nip what I'm trying to say is I have
absolutely no game but yesterday all
today's standards but these are still
bloody awkward to listen to even by my
standards however for consistency I need
to include these in the video
as requested for tilapia fillets
thank you
I cannot wait to try this famous Ceviche
I thought you only made that for special
occasions or when you're trying to get
laid
thanks Cindy
happy to help boss
sorry about her
I like her she's funny
and informative
so what's the special occasion
or do you just want to get laid
I I yeah I I don't know how to answer
that
I guess sleeping with make account is a
special occasion
oh
okay
um I wow so
it
do you want to go in my office I kind of
live in there and there's a lock on the
door
well maybe you should take a shower
first you're cute but honey you stink
yeah right yeah sorry about that never
really feels like I can take a break
personal hygiene has been slipping for a
while now
bus talking or showering mister I need
to get back to the aquarium where people
are gonna suspect something's up
oh my god did you try the fish tacos
they're so freaking good
right if they lived with this we could
have overthrown a Black Tusk hindsight
I'm glad you made it out me too
I wish more of us made it nope stop
we can't go there
we start crying when I stop
hey Manny
tell your girl thanks
hey keep it down
what we're not public
[__] Mario have you tried the ceviche of
course you gotta have some I'm good
you're missing out you pregnant or
something okay no more toilet wine for
you Manny can you handle him of course
say
we are telling people oh [__] you're
gonna be your dad hey friend I really
like this girl can you just please shut
the [__] up
you knocked her up I hope you like it
okay I think it's time for bed I'll take
care of our boy go get your girl
we need to talk
oh no uh
did I do something wrong
oh you're not in trouble or anything
well at least I hope not
okay now you're scaring me
we're adults we're smart
college educated and all that are you
interviewing me for a job
no I just mean we aren't stupid and I'm
a scientist so I know how reproduction
works
okay now you've lost me
we've been having fun for a couple of
months
has it really been that long already
we've been having uninterrupted fun for
the last eight weeks
this may be my longest relationship
be serious
I am
I really like you Mari I like you too I
like you so much we've been having
unprotected sex for eight weeks with no
breaks
aren't you on birth control
where would I get birth control
are you pregnant
for now what do you mean for now I mean
I've been pregnant before I've taken
care of it or my body has so
the odds of this baby making it to term
with minimal access to modern medicine
was a questionable diet and high stress
is not great
do you want to have a kid with me
well we've only known each other for a
couple of months
but
honestly I couldn't imagine a better
person to have a kid with
how can I help
uh I guess send your agents to read a
pharmacy for prenatal vitamins and find
a midwife
maybe we could build a barn for me to
give birth and I don't know we could die
tomorrow or it could be a hundred none
of those make sense
well then I guess I'll plan for a
hundred and be happy if we see tomorrow
marising has been located at the Manning
National Zoo
at the entrance agents are immediately
met with heavy Black Tusk resistance
while these aren't an issue for the
agents to dispatch they are now running
against the clock with hostiles aware of
the division being on site they need to
move fast before Mario's once again
moved on
radio we intercepted
we need to secure the asset I'm near the
Aquarium I'll handle Mari remember that
said keep her stressed low handle The
Intruders and start evacuation
procedures I'll keep her calm and move
to the Rendezvous copy about
through the intercepted comms the black
tasks have been instructed to keep Mari
calm and comfortable but the agents
would also learn of her location
fighting through hordes of Black Tusk on
their way to the aquarium including some
warhounds the agents consider themselves
lucky not having similar Doggers that
were seen at the end of the last Manhunt
structure you'll have to contend with
predation and weather if you convert the
enclosure into a fish farm
sure there aren't any clocks in there
really doesn't feel very safe I promise
no Crocs skaters or apex predators of
any kind are in the enclosures
pushing through the aquarium it appears
that Murray has been moved on
Mari was the director of the DC Aquarium
before she turned it into a fish farm
they probably want her to set up a
similar operation for the Black Tusk
food security is a powerful motivator
agent I've got eyes on Mari near the
Savannah
agents make their way over to the
you can't let the division destroy the
clinic we won't we should stay and fight
don't worry the Black Tusk will stop the
division thank you
get the patients out of here
they're running away from us
but we're trying to help them
I will let you take them
I feel that Murray isn't the only
pregnant woman on site they seem to be
using this area of the zoo as a clinic
it also shows that the Personnel the
agents have been rescuing are only some
of many civilians that the black task
have been working with the propaganda
machine is going strong
all these plants must be edible you
could root the cuttings and grow them on
top of the fish tanks you're not worried
about predation as long as you keep the
Dome closed you shouldn't have to worry
about boys stealing the fish
the plants on top offer additional
protection
it's also nicer to work inside during a
storm and it's closer to the clinic
honestly you don't need all of this to
build a fish farm you're recommending we
look for another site for the operation
I'm recommending you use the
infrastructure of a zoo for a zoo We
need sustainable food for the community
if we want people to come back and when
people are back they're going to be
bored and want to go on adventures
experience new things still want to go
to the zoo or the aquarium yes but
turning the aquarium into a fish farm we
already had a fish farm turning the
cross pet into a trout hole is very
different the exhibits weren't built for
people to grow food they were built to
keep the animals in foreign
as the agents move through the compound
they intercept quite a number of hostile
comms the black tasks are evacuating
quite a large number of personnel and
Murray has been moved along hastily
agent there's movement in the bamboo
forest near the panda enclosure I think
they're getting ready for another
extraction
Wally directs us to the next extraction
Point Murray could be on this one so the
agents waste no time in making it over
there
hey I think we should get you out of
here just in case something wrong
nothing you should worry about but I
prefer to get you somewhere more secure
too many access points we use extraction
send the Hilo meet us at the atrium
realizing that the agents are getting
close and that nothing seems to be
slowing them down the black task moved
Murray towards an extraction point
I'll let you know when it's safe to come
out
[Music]
you'll be safe in there I'll let you
know when you can come out
someone is looking out for Murray agents
will need to worry about this later as
they engage in combat at the atrium with
one of the Black Tusk leaders that have
been looking after Murray
negative Atrium is compromised new
rendezvous at the arena
eventually the leader would be taken
down and Murray could be heard of the
comms
Manny we sort of agreed he should sit
this one out that was probably a good
idea Torres is on her way I'll tell
Manny you're okay no please don't
wait until we're back in case anything
happens to us I don't want to get his
hopes up
how we've not quite done yet Murray was
relocated to the arena where another
black tuscalida is waiting to extract
her
don't shoot it's me I'm coming out
agent you can shoot a flare Taurus is on
her way
[Music]
however when firing off the flare to
bring tourism the agents in Murray
weren't the only ones left on site
[Music]
what you miss me or something
thank you agent
are you okay
did they hear you hey I'm fine I'm fine
hey baby
so far so good
even got some prenatal vitamins
and a scam
yeah everything's normal
[Music]
we're not out of the woods but their
doctors say she looks healthy
they took care of you you were safe with
them no
no I wasn't safe with them
that psycho was only good to me because
she knew she needed me alive to get what
she wants what what does she want
for you to give her the White House
and to install her organization as
rightful military force
stand down and give her legitimacy what
else did you expect from a woman like
that maybe we should just give her what
she wants [__] that
yeah I'm with Wally giving in to people
like that never ends well we can't do
this alone well we don't have to
where's Vic Sokolova has him
well then you get him back
he knows her operation he helped build
it
you want to take her down and you want
to protect your family get Vic
where's Kelso back in New York we need
to get sleep we have a big day tomorrow
thank you
that I just wanted to let you know the
asset is in place and awaits your orders
excellence
Mari very obviously doesn't buy into
what Natalia has been doing she is
certain that this whole thing was just a
part of Natalia's plan of manipulation a
plan to mislead and confuse many in the
team into just handing over the White
House and to be fair it's been working
look at how many reacted through this
whole Manhunt in the state he's now in
he seems almost defeated
but this is where Mario voices up and
tells him to snap out of it unlike many
she sees right through it Natalia is
crazy she needs to be stopped and Wally
100 agrees with her
first things first they need to get
Vikram Malik back he has once again been
captured by the Black Tusk
as we've found out over this last season
he played a part in building her
operation he has the information they
need to take it down
are you really okay
yes stop treating me like I'm made of
glass
I'm not doing that
man yes you are
we should get some sleep
you should be working
[Applause]
yeah we can take a break
but tomorrow we get back to work
what does she want with you anyway
same thing you do
she wants a baby
no what is what is wrong with you she
wanted me to set up a fish farm at the
zoo
figured if I could repurpose the
exhibits of the aquarium to feed the
community
do something similar there
that's actually a pretty good idea
that's not the worst idea
why the hell would they want to try to
maintain a fish farm at a zoo
I thought their whole thing was being
creepy infiltrating Raiders with too
much Tech and no morality
she's an heiress she's probably tired of
other caress the soldiers stink
she's looking for something more stable
she's recruiting
trying to turn our people to her side
maybe she's ready for something bigger
if she controls the food supply and
offers protection and stability
she could turn the nation
or maybe the fish farm wasn't for her
I don't know I'm going to bed
so now that the season is wrapped up
there are a couple of big topics we need
to discuss
has Natalia actually turned good or as
Murray lost the plot what is the asset
Natalia was talking about and who was
the random unnamed person who helped
Mario out at the zoo and gave her the
division comps
let's start with what I sort of see as
the obvious one is Natalya in the Black
Tusk the good guys now
in my opinion absolutely not
I've been harping on about this since
the first minor Mission this season it
has all just screened as Natalia is
playing the same plan but trying a
different direction
I agree with what Mari said about
Natalia trying to get many to just hand
over the White House but I don't think
Mario Wally would ever let this happen
however I think this is only part of
what Natalia was trying to do with this
new approach I mean she was successful
with many he looks shattered like he
needs to take some sort of sabbatical or
something but look at what we found out
in their last mission
our Personnel that we've been bringing
back look to only be a fraction of who
Natalia has brought under her wing
there were a lot of people being
evacuated from the zoo while we were
there and from the sounds of it they
completely buy into what Natalia is
selling they were actually scared of the
division
it would seem that the puppet master has
successfully begun controlling the way
the public see her in the Black Tusk
to be fair she should have started doing
this a long time ago
what many said there about whoever
controls the food and can provide
security will have the support of the
people isn't necessarily untrue
but I think on a much more basic level
if Natalia wanted to take control of DC
or the US she was always going to have a
much easier time if she had the general
public on her side
but she has a hell of a job ahead of her
looking at the Black Tusk from the
outside they don't exactly scream
friendly with their dark uniforms robot
attack dogs and other giant Tech they
leave all over the place as well as the
fact that they have mowed down an
unimaginable number of jtf since they've
first been in the city
maybe this is where the true sun's
coming
it did always seem strange that she
would bring them on board they didn't
really have a lot to offer her
perhaps they will be the ones that
handle the more civilian-facing missions
while the black tasks work on the more
undercover projects in the background so
the true Sons can gather all of the
negative press while Natalya continues
to boost the Black Tusk
anyway summing up with the Natalia is
now good no she is not her goal is still
the same as it has always been she is
simply just placing a bit more focus on
the black tusk's Public Image
so who's the asset Natalia was talking
about and what is Natalia going to do
with them
it could be easy to assume after this
last season of rescuing lesser-known
characters that perhaps one of them has
been turned by Natalya and is ready to
play out some sort of sabotage on many
or the castle cinnamon
but I don't think this is the case
all of them have very close
relationships with many before they were
captured and none of their personalities
seem like the type to do this
obviously we could be surprised but it
still doesn't feel right to me instead I
believe the asset to be something else
in the past we've heard Natalya use
similar language during the burden
Shafer main hunt and what they were
referring to as the asset then was a
hunter
so I'm going to say that this is what
she's put in place
but to do what
well I think this is where my last
question comes in who was the person
behind the Voice who helped keep Murray
safe during her rescue
take this put it in your ear I'll let
you know when it's safe to come out
[Music]
you'll be safe in there I'll let you
know when you can come out
when I first heard the voice like most I
assume I noticed there wasn't a name
attached to the subtitles
my mind went straight to things like
maybe it was a jtf officer who had
infiltrated the compound who was getting
ready to extract her once we had dealt
with the last of the hostiles or maybe
it was a Defector within the Black Tusk
ranks who had managed to get hold of the
division comms piece
but then we'll get to the end of the
mission and someone familiar that we've
seen once before would show himself
now I'll admit it the voice being a
hunter or more specifically the
recruiter didn't fit for me
but the more time I spent trying to
prove this wrong the more likely it
ended up becoming
I went back through all of my mind maps
Venn diagrams and whiteboards that I've
used to piece all the stories together
over the years across the different
media types and games I looked through
all the past and current characters to
try and make sense of it and who could
have stepped in at the last minute there
but I keep coming up blank
however when I stood back and actually
assessed the potential significance of
those couple of lines along with
Natalia's mention of the asset the scene
showing the recruiter and the fact that
a lot of the comms this season coming
out of The Descent game mode have been
bringing a lot of light to the role of
the hunters it's hard not to come to the
conclusion that this was the voice of
the recruiter
but then why would he help marry
I mean we all love the hunters but when
it comes to agents versus Hunters
they're the bad guys right
I don't think this is a situation where
the voice actor maybe didn't portray the
character in the correct way because I
regularly chat to the overlord of all
that is the division law and she is most
certainly not someone who would settle
for a mediocre attempt at voicing one of
her creations
so if that was the recruiter it kind of
sounded like a decent guy not the bad
guy you would expect
well like everything in this game I
think there's a lot more to it
based on the Intel we're receiving from
The Descent comms it's looking very
likely that one of the first
speculations around what we thought the
hunters were may actually be pretty
close
I put out a video my first speculation
video actually five years ago called who
are the hunters to date this is still
the most popular video I've ever
released which is sad because it was
actually demonetized almost immediately
by Ubisoft because they didn't like some
of the survival footage I used
apparently but we won't talk about that
right now basically the most favored
speculation I could talk to at the time
was that the hunters were the third wave
now I don't think that they're the third
wave but I believe their position
through this whole thing is very similar
to what we were talking about way back
then they were put in place as sort of a
division agent control system
I say division agent rather than rogue
agent because there seems to be a very
blurry line between these two things
these days so for the purpose of this
video Let's just Round Up Rogues and
division agents as the same thing and
Hunters are a suppression system put in
place to control them if needed
this isn't meant to be an agent versus
Hunter video because I feel the answer
to that is pretty clear
if pitted against each other one-on-one
not the player character but an average
division agent versus a hunter the agent
wouldn't stand a chance
this isn't because the shd agent is
worse than the hunter they just have
very different functions
agents are there to save what remains
work closely with those in society to
help rebuild while fighting back against
any hostile uprisings they may encounter
Hunters they're specialized in doing
exactly what their name suggests hunt
down a Target and eliminate
I think of the hunters as being like a
ghost recon ghost no I'm not saying that
Ghost Recon is the same universe as the
division that has been confirmed as
false many times I'm just using them as
an example
Hunters are super Black Ops except while
ghosts are still formidable on their own
they're most effective in a small Squad
we're Hunters work solo even agents
while deployed in cells are perfectly
capable working alone unless they're
running raids or recursions at the team
basically the hunters are far more
highly trained combat units than the
agents but their purpose is much
narrower
rather than being trained the hunters
are recruited it's the recruiter
picked before the outbreak the hunters
were recruited from various branches of
Special Forces so these guys are
American troops super deadly troops but
still people fighting for their country
why do I think this matters
while Calvin McManus isn't exactly a
good guy it would seem and the hunters
do report directly to him they aren't
just Mindless killing machines
I don't think they want to see U.S
civilians being killed on mass by the
Black Tusk division agents or anyone
else stuck in this conflict and I think
there is the potential there that the
recruiter is going a little off Mission
well at least a little bit off kelvin's
mission
let's assume for a second there that the
Hunter's whole mission that they have
been given was to eliminate division
agents who have gone off mission
as things currently are it isn't really
clear who is and isn't on Mission so
perhaps the hunters or at least their
leader the recruiter is feeling a little
conflicted in the direction everything
is headed
also given that they're using at least
one of the three AI systems it's
possible they have hacked into it and
seen everything that has been going on
like Aaron Keener did
maybe the recruiter is looking for
someone on the other side of this war to
converse with about this whole thing
someone he sees is an equal with a
similar moral compass
someone who can help bring balance to
the situation and this is why he's been
watching us for so long now he's been
assessing whether we can be trusted
remember Calvin and Natalia wouldn't
exactly be able to recognize us if we
were recruited as we all know Hunters
don't talk and their identity is hidden
by a mask we might not even be the first
division agent that has been recruited
into the hunter ranks
this has been an interesting season for
the story we still have more of our
Personnel to rescue but it's looking
more and more like Natalia's finding
success and bringing the general public
over to a side and that the division are
only losing support
it's also very cool to see the recruiter
make another appearance and with the
nature of The Descent coms still coming
through I suspect we'll be hearing more
about him soon
anyway if you've made it this far I hope
you've enjoyed this compilation video on
year 5 season 1. season 2 isn't far away
now so we should see who Natalia's asset
is soon but who do you think it is let
me know in the comments thank you very
much for watching and extremist malice
extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]